hey man what do you want to watch what's
that movie the one on Netflix the one
with the actor oh uh beige action
thriller yeah that one I don't know man
it has really bad reviews bro you can't
trust the critics no yeah for sure they
get it wrong a lot of the time but
usually if all of them are saying it's
bad it's probably bad you can't trust
the critics bro some sometimes they're
right on the night of June 2nd 1989 a
movie critic broke into my home murdered
my parents and left me one copy of Danny
DeVito's twins I did not like the movie
and I haven't trusted movie critics
since
you didn't like twins really that's the
part of the story you can't believe it
was Ebert by the way all the audience
reviews are bad too so amateur critics
critics in the making whatever man let's
watch it we'll watch it wow that movie
was asked oh look who's the critic now
because it's true what they say what
Everyone's a Critic okay